when the movie was finished my son was
upset with
me for kissing james franco
and my daughter was upset with me for
james franco kissing me
[Music]
fast times at ridgemont high
it was
my second
movie and i was
in my parents garage my agent tracked me
down at their house and said um
that there was this
movie and and that uh i should get a
hold of the book
so i went out and i got the book and i
read it
and i immediately recognized this guy do
you ever fear for your life we'll sue
out surfing's not a sport it's a way of
life no hobby so we're looking at that
wave and saying hey bud
let's party
i had grown up with a
kid that was real similar to that
and i thought yeah i could find the
music of this and then
i went in
to audition it was a disaster i was
never good at auditioning
but so there was a casting director on
that movie named don phillips who was
extremely important to many careers he
was a an actor lover he really cared
about people and he saw
things that maybe you weren't even
presenting and so he convinced them to
see me again and
pushed and pushed and the next thing i
knew i got the part and uh had a blast
wait a minute there's no birthday party
here
what's the reason for your truancy
just couldn't make it on time so much of
it came from this one character that
grew up in malibu and uh that i had
known you know throughout my teens
it was a combination of
and i can't remember what blend of this
is now but
of what cameron crowe had written
and this this one particular guy that i
knew and it just
that merger was where i went
do you have a guy like me in class every
year
you know a guy who you make an example
of i recently ran into him for the first
time we were passing on a trail to and
from the beach
and this
man with his wife and children was
walking down the path and
who spoke in a very
articulate way and
greeted me knowing you know he'd had the
advantage of watching me age so he knew
that it was me but then he had to
introduce himself and i i couldn't
believe that it was him but i had never
told anybody who it was so i don't think
i don't think he knows
mystic river
clinton i had met and talked about
another movie that i didn't feel like
was something
right for me to do
he made that movie and then i didn't
know if i'd ever hear from him again
because i
had not wanted to do and then but he
came back and and offered me this one
and
i probably got about 10 pages in and
called him and i said this is a beast
let's go ask you something jimmy
shoot
why do you hate that kid so bad
that's not hate just done that little
mute [ __ ] spooky out sometimes what i
have always found and this is definitely
true of of that mystic river is that
when the character you're playing
has a kind of confidence and comfort
with themself
that you that you kind of inhabit that
feeling you're able to take that part of
yourself and feel that way
when you have somebody that's extremely
insecure with themself you kind of
inhabit that feeling and that generally
is the measure of whether you had a good
time or a bad time on a movie
my approach to that was very much i had
read it the first time
never read it again when i would read
the script i'd skip over the scene and i
just put it off until the day and then
clint eastwood
uh did a really smart thing because he
he wanted me to be able to
give it all the fight i had so he got
instead of what was scripted as i think
three people to because i think any
grown man can
struggle a lot with three people doesn't
mean they're going to dominate the three
people i was easily going to be
dominated by the three of them but not
stopped especially if you want to give
it your all and you don't want to hurt
anybody
making a movie so he put like 15
and they locked up every part of my body
so i could really
go and so we did it in very few minute
takes
milk
so because you
go in very early in the morning i needed
a wake up and where i lived was on the
other side of the golden gate bridge
come in over that again on lombard
street and right at the corner to
visadero which is where you would go to
summit
to look down into the castro which is
where we shot most of the movie there
was little hot wings place so about
seven eight o'clock in the morning stop
in there grab the hot wings
and i drive up that would sort of make
me feel like it wasn't early morning
eating that way just as it would kind of
come over the summit
my driver chat would
hit the cd player
uh queued up and uh just as we'd see the
castro its reigning men would be playing
and it was time for another day
of work on
milk 40 years old and i haven't done a
thing
in prada
you keep eating this cake you're gonna
be fat by the time you're vicki
that's if i ever get to 50 oh
happy birthday old man it was a little
bit unique because
there was so much archival footage that
really gave you such a round sense of
the personality of the real harvey milk
and so many of
those who were part of his campaigns and
his closest friends who were still
around and and uh
you know kind of
gave the movie their embrace and so we
had the availability of those people to
check in with but
essentially for me it was putting all of
the footage i had about
three hours of random footage and then a
whole documentary
and i just kept it on a loop all around
a loop from a couple of months
where i was living and just let it
get in there because he had a
such a a beautiful personality that you
kind of felt like when somebody asked
that question you know who who
who who's no longer living would you
have liked to have met i really felt
like i was
missing out on that
on having met him
there's a scene in that movie
which is where harvey milk wins
his first election
that i remember i think we all in a room
kind of whatever it was that gus vanzant
did that created the feeling of all
those people that had invested so much
to make that happen that that really
kind of caught on a moment where you
felt like you were in really in that
space
i am sam
that was one of the movies i had the
best time on a really great group of
people
the director jesse nelson
and michelle pfeiffer we
really had
it was a very good spirit on that on
that set i didn't even know where to
start but i knew i wanted to do it and
so then i went um
[Music]
there's a
place locally in los angeles in west los
angeles
uh that is uh like
where
mentally challenged
young people
go
to
be educated through doing arts and
crafts
and so i was able to
go
as if a student and spend
a lot of time with a lot of different
rhythms of spectrums you know different
different uh kids with
very different you know and young adults
very different uh
rhythms
and bit by bit you know you you'd go
you'd spend time like that and then
you'd go back home at night and you'd
read the script
you say this
this is what
parts of these things are going to work
best
you need a pair of good sturdy school
shoes these are sturdy very their arches
are very important now sturdy is boring
sam their circle of
sam's friends
and i thought that there would be
nothing to keep me
uh at least in my own
judgment of it honest
than if the circle of friends were cast
from
this arts place that i had been working
or or observing at and the director was
very game
to do that very smart she really does i
think she's really beautiful yeah of
course she she looks smart she's already
reading the paper
so i wouldn't know whether i was in or
out sometimes
it you know and became far less
self-conscious about it very quickly and
what was also interesting is they had
known me now for months before they got
cast in the movie had never seen me as
sam
and didn't bat a an eye it was just as
if it was still you know
sean but i'm supposed to call him sam
[Music]
i just didn't want to
do a fake looking fall and i'm looking
at this cake
and i realized i just
put the cake down and i took
some of the frosting and went to a spot
on the floor next to the stairs and put
the frosting there and just made a slick
spot and then i just geared myself up
now i didn't just get myself up it's
like i mean i put elbow you know padded
and all of that
and i just decided i'm just gonna run at
that thing and when my left foot goes
forward into that
it's just i'm not i'm gonna try to just
do this straight and see if that thing
takes me down
[Music]
and it did it knocked my feet right out
from under me
the thin red line
i always kind of graph things and
try to you know get in there and
and craft something that i can rely on
if the instincts aren't bringing it on
the day right and also you know they're
paying attention to where i came from
where i'm going just the basics of
acting
but terry
you know it's true of i think film in
general but but nowhere in my experience
more extreme than with terry that he
writes the script three times he writes
it when he writes it he writes it when
he shoots it he rewrites it in the
editing room and
can be completely different films
completely different
demand on what the character one is
playing is serving so it's kind of this
ephemeral thing it became more
seen
racine playing and because i think that
he likes to have
things that become colors on his palette
and then he's going to paint
when you're absent
this is a sea company of which i'm first
sergeant i run this outfit the captain
starts he's the co
but i'm the guy who runs it nobody's
gonna fail at him
you're just another mouth for me to feed
normally you'd be court-martialed with
any scene of of substance in terms of
dialogue
we also shot an alternate that was
silent so that we were working on a
behavioral version and this wasn't just
as an exercise because as it turns out
in a lot of cases throughout with all
the characters in that movie there's a
lot of these silent vignettes that
you'll see or vignettes under music
that also had been played out
with dialogue as dialogue scenes
moving out five minutes terry'd come in
and say how how would you two
communicate that if you didn't have any
words
you know
sometimes there's nowhere to go with
that and and other times some
interesting things came out of it
dead man walking
i went down and spent some time
in louisiana just
the first trip was really just to tape
people talking uh
accents that were specific to the areas
and
and to do it both men and women so that
you're just really finding the sounds
not over influenced by a character
and then sister prejean who had written
a book took me up to angola penitentiary
to the death row to meet with some
people that she counseled you know just
to kind of get some background
on it what the trust message is private
property
[Music]
these things
sometimes
you know there was there was the one
very brutal scene
where the murder and raping all that
stuff happened
i remember thinking i i don't know that
i want to do this anymore
just felt really really really ugly
um and and i think that that was
a kind of beginning of a corrosion of
the joy that i typically would have had
in acting that period though a great job
a great job with you know great people
i it was it was just there you know
there can be one scene that that
changes the landscape a little bit
i'm gonna die
you know the truth the truth has made
you free
y'all know the truth about me
i'm going to a better place i'm not
worried about nothing
i think we all
face our own
mortality at some point
um and there is something about that
struggle with the defiance and the
withholding of the truth
you know the famous line of the thing is
that you're from the truth will set you
free i think that's you know relatable
whether we're talking about the death
penalty or anything a
murderer or anything else tomorrow's the
day of your execution you're bound to be
under stress and the test often mistakes
stress for dishonesty no problem i'm
home for you
you've been reading your bible
i tried to last night
makes me want to sleep
trying to stay conscious
the character is in control of so little
in his life
that
it was like for example
the look of the character the hair it
was it was one of the available
anchors into identity you know so that a
lot of care was taken with that
21 grams
you know who of us wouldn't be provoked
by the notion of carrying around
somebody else's heart in the way that we
associate the heart
with
our our care and our love and and and
all of that it makes no scientific sense
but it's embedded in us that our heart
is this place that holds such personal
things
and so
what an interesting story is somebody
who's kind of going off in search of
connection to the deceased who allowed
him to live who will be the first to
lose his life
he
in the coma
[Music]
or me it was clear reading the
screenplay
that this was an expression of how
[Music]
we experience our lives in terms of time
what's
literally present
what's metaphorically present what's
sort of spiritually present and what's
distant in all of those ways and so
that was clear and i also
he's a very clear guide
so you never
you know were without the dictionary to
look up the word of what the day meant
because you had in alejandro that
clarity of storytelling
that he he knew what he was after
asphyxiated it's an awful death paul you
can't imagine it
at least here we can help you you can
help me
die better
that's what you're saying you can help
me die better
in a lot of stories
there there can be the demand to really
understand
the technicalities of a certain world so
that it's second nature
and other times the characters are just
a different version of one's own
experience
and so
when you have a really good script in
the latter category which this one was
there ends up being not much to tell
it's it's directly from the script to
the actor and the director and actor
together
flag day
the great thing about the experience was
was working with my daughter dylan
uh who's just extraordinary in the movie
and the the awful thing about
that movie was acting and directing was
not something i would choose to do um it
was it really happened we were kind of
in a pinch where i had to come in
and and do it i'm really glad it
happened i i just was immediately
engaged by jez butterworth's screenplay
just did stupid things you know i'm
angry at you
you're smarter than that
don't think i couldn't tell
it's not my first rodeo
have you done drugs
never any parent is going to recognize
times where they didn't offer their
entire authentic self to their children
it's just you know it's just that's a
kind of a hellish thing to unwind and
there was something that just i felt was
very moving in this situation where with
a father who's he's he's very um
truth-resistant dad what do you do
you mean what do i do i mean for a
living what do you do for a living you
know what i do for living
i'm an entrepreneur which develops a
daughter who is a truth seeker and uh so
those are dynamics that were just very
uh active and playable
sweet and low down
sometimes it's just about
where you kind of catch the music of
something and you feel like okay i can i
i want to i want to see where this goes
and that was one of those very much so
but what was interesting
is that he'd written
what in my view was a pretty extreme
character
and he never asked me what i was going
to do with it he never saw what i was
going to do with it until the first day
of shooting where'd you learn to play
that thing like that yeah i never heard
guitar sound so good yeah i'm the
greatest in the world well you know in
france's django
and then
we shot the first take of the first
scene
and you know it was pretty clear that i
had a certain flamboyance of character
uh that was very specific
and he never said a word about it
she said okay should we do another one
should we do it and so i just figured
well i guess he's okay with the music i
heard in my head so here we go
[Music]
yeah that was a a difficult one because
i didn't play guitar
and i had about four months as i
remember to
to learn the fingering on 30 pieces i
think in the oh in the final film i
think there's about eight or nine pieces
represented
so i
uh
ended up
moving in with my guitar teacher and if
you know virtually i had i was on
another
job in europe
and i had like you know the two twin
beds in the room and if i would wake up
at two in the morning we would work
until it was tired enough to go back to
sleep if it would just work with every
spare hour
on the fingering
you would never would have wanted to
hear my playing
but i did get to where i was pretty
adept at the at the fingering and it was
a lot of work and i never wanted to
touch a guitar again afterwards